What will happen?
The Joe Rogan experience,
I watched a documentary called,
what the hell have you seen?
It's like,
yeah,
it's filled with a lot of propaganda from Canada at them.
Those guys,
again,
like the Nazis,
I remember the,
it's,
they used a lot of discredited studies and there's a lot of epidemiology studies
that'll connect things that bond mula she does that.
What does that mean?
Like an epidemic or he's like,
no,
we could pull up what the actual pulled something up and etiology.
But the way I would describe it as they would do these studies,
and essentially it would be,
they would,
they would ask you what you eat on a daily basis.
How often do you eat meat?
How,
and it's basically a survey.
And in,
in that survey they would say,
well,
there's a direct correlation between people that eat meat and diabetes.
So let's pull up the definitions.
Oh,
I see.
But the problem is what is causing here a branch of medicine,
which deals with incidents,
distribution and possible control of diseases and other factors relating to
health.
Um,
so when they're,
when they're dealing with incidents,
right?
They're dealing with,
how often do you eat red meat?
How often do you eat this?
How often do you eat that?
And then they find,
oh,
well there's more instances of diabetes and people that eat meat.
Okay,
but is it people that eat meat and vegetables or is it people that eat meat and
vegetables and diet coke and sugary sodas and ice cream and French fries,
and how are they eating their meat?
Are they eating cheeseburgers for some bullshit fast food place?
Are they eating grass fed steak?
Are they eating grass fed steak and vegetables?
And there's very little evidence that shows there's anything wrong with eating
meat.
If you follow a normal healthy,
what they would call it,
primal diet eating,
cut out all the grains,
cut on all the sugar,
cut out all the bullshit,
eat vegetables and meat.
And there's almost nothing.
I mean unless you have some very unusual,
rare condition where you are either allergic to meat or you have some very
strange,
uh,
digestive system where you find you have allergies to it or you have real
problems digesting it or you have real problems with high cholesterol foods,
which is very rare as well.
Most of what you're getting is vegan propaganda.
People that want other people to be convinced that the way that they're living
is the correct way and that eating meat is,
is physically bad for you and it's causing all these harms.
What's causing all the harm people physically is the modern American diet and
that's been pretty established.
Yes,
that's right.
And there are clear ethical reasons to be Vegan in the,
it takes you out of the exploitation of animals.
But that documentary,
what the health that I watched was like,
you know,
not be a vegetarian for years and this light and I've gone back and forth to
veganism because I felt God,
Jesus Christ,
man,
there's enough things in my life I'm not doing without not been out.
I have an egg without feeling guilty for pasture raised eggs.
If you get them from a good farm,
the chickens are just hanging out now.
They'll confident in these animals in the way.
Well,
one by one,
slowly Dulcie eliminate in
terrible fertilize.
Nine of them to coyotes.
Just last month,
maybe two months ago,
I said pretty heavy.
So it was a heavy toll.
Yeah.
Well we had a fire out here and the chicken coop burnt down.
We got a smaller chicken coop and the coyote is figured out how to get into it
more when we're at home and came home to just feathers everywhere.
It was disgusting.
Brutal.
They're brutal little monsters.
Coyotes.
Yeah.
You know ungovernable they're the reason why I'm want to have rats everywhere
too.
All right.
So yeah.
Could I live in lion king was right.
So like,
hey though,
um,
the thing that about that Vegan documentary mate is that it,
it tuned in to my preexisting belief when it said stuff like,
oh,
the diabetes associations,
they are funded by these meat and dairy organizations in these pharmaceutical
companies.
The cancer organizations similarly accepts donations from these organizations.
And it made me recognize my preexisting idea to I come to it with is,
you know,
like that whole pyramid of these are the things you should eat.
Bread,
milk,
like,
you know,
just with the figs that it was easy and cheap to produce and that we're
profitable and they used it.
I think that they really did used to think that breadwinner and grains are the
most important.
Do you think they felt that?
I think they did.
I think they thought it was,
it was filling and it provided energy.
And I don't think they understood well.
There was no talk of gluten intolerance when we were young.
It didn't exist and there was no understanding of excess carbs and excess carbs
leads to excess body weight and it makes you,
makes you store fat.
And people didn't think about it that way.
They didn't understand there was,
the thing about nutrition is in nutrition,
science is a,
it's a body of knowledge that's constantly added to.
Yeah.
And in fact,
perhaps most things are,
who knows what misapprehensions and ignorance we toil on.
Yeah.
That will be revealed to us.